said you were
thinking about writing a book or you're
going to write a psychedelic inspired
book right
absolutely yeah what's it you you what's
it going to be called
how psychedelic saved my life tell me
how they saved your life man
well i think again the rabbit hole yes i
started reading a lot of a lot of
literature
about um just dosing what different
doses could do for you
and it just all depends on the effect
that you want
you know what i mean so um i started
micro dosing
in the middle of the wild [ __ ] that was
going on
of course of course i started micro
dosing
i'm not gonna say like oh it was like
this magical
[ __ ] just wake up and everything is
you know chipper
right right right it was like slowly
over time like i started to gain a
little more clarity
and uh you know it just it just kind of
helped me find
not even like a happiness but it just
helped me find like like the
like the beauty and a lot of [ __ ] you
know i mean like i'd go outside and be
like damn
that's a [ __ ] beautiful flower you
know right
i would have never stopped before you
know so i just i don't know it just
and i was micro dosing so it wasn't like
making me like hallucinations
or nothing yeah it was just like um
kind of just uplifting my days you know
when it was going on
and i think um you know from there
that was like lsd micro dosing in water
and then now i do shroom tea most of the
time
yes see i've never done the shroom tea
so how much will you put in the tea
like because it depends really like
depending on what kind of day you're
trying to have yeah like i like a light
vibe like i might put
a half a quarter okay to the whole pot
which is like you know six probably six
tea bags
right and um
that right there like if you want to get
[ __ ] up you still can if you drink you
know all of it more than a few glasses
you know what i'm saying like you'll
definitely get [ __ ] up but
i just sip it slow i'll be in the studio
working creating [ __ ] not super slow and
it's just
it's like a it's like a different type
of vibe man it's just it's like uh
like it helps my brain in different
types of nature so when you say
psychedelics help save your life
do you would you say because i for
people who don't know i think a lot of
people don't understand like
the therapeutic benefits of
of shrooms and even mdma you know what
i'm saying in certain instances but
but is that would you consider like your
experience with psychedelics to be
therapeutic
absolutely it didn't used to be right it
used to be more probably recreational
right
used to be yeah it was it was
recreational and it's like i was sitting
in between
where like the the positive effects
would be
you know there's like the hero dose
which is
all all i mean yeah it's going to make
you discover yourself
and then there's the micro dose which is
you know for your mental health
right you know just just like again yeah
if you micro dose you can have a
productive day you go to work you can
you know do all that should have a more
productive day
yes that's i think that's why people do
it yeah so you haven't done the hero
does yet
because i remember we talked and you
were saying that you you want to do it
but
but you're not ready yet yeah it's just
gotta get out
you know i'm still like coming out the
dark space i want to be fully out before
because that's something that's
something that's like
serious well you know that's that's man
it's
for me look shrooms never really sat
well with me
uh when i was younger like when we were
taking shrooms recreationally like
i i used to bat trip like all the time
wow i mean like
and i don't want to say like bad trip is
so you know overused but
right right i mean just like you know
that uncomfortable
kind of dark feeling yeah it turned into
a [ __ ]
a burton movie you know for sure like
that's
that's how a lot of my trips started to
feel like
you know so i think shrooms my love for
shrooms came
back when i started micro dosing shrooms
and making tea and stuff like that
because i was like
okay this is the dose that my body
appreciates right this is what mine this
is exactly what i like you know what i
mean
and it has been like i said it's been
therapeutic life-changing since then
have you dabbled in uh in dmt yet
no it's very uh crack headish
i mean you literally smoke it out of a
crack pipe so just be
if you ever decide to do that i'm i'm
definitely not um
you're going to disappoint anything out
of a crack you're going to disappear for
15 minutes
just you're gone yeah i've heard i mean
a lot of my friends have done it you
know
and and stuff like that but that [ __ ]
and then the other [ __ ] is the ayahuasca
which is like a tea but that you you got
to do with a shaman
go to costa rica you know i mean you
could do it in orange county you know
what i mean
yeah send me the address i'm gonna go
yeah nah nah that's told me i think i
think
like uh money man just tweeted this the
other day he was like we're not doing
uh pills no more only shrooms he was
like the first
rapper in that kind of space that i saw
kind of say that you know what i mean
cause i'm like a lot of these kids are
so [ __ ]
you know perked out fentanyl and all
this [ __ ] and it's like man i think i
think
shrooms has got to be the next wave bro
and that [ __ ] is
all them pills and all them opioids and
all that [ __ ] is so
garbage man yeah so garbage this is
dangerous
i feel like you're gambling with your
life every time you do it because you
don't know what the [ __ ] you're getting
it's it's like it's it's a sad thing to
see bro for real because
you know you're only you're only here
one time
it just takes one bad pill yes take you
off the map
you're only here once man